Simplifica "x" al cubo
elevada a la cuarta potencia
por "x" cuadrada elevada a la quinta potencia.
Para hacer esto usaremos
la propiedad de potenciación de exponentes,
en ocasiones denominada la regla de potencias,
la cual nos dice que si tenemos
"x" elevado a la potencia "a"
y esto a la vez elevado a la potencia "b",
esto es igual a "x" elevado a la potencia "a" por "b",
y para ver por qué esto funciona,
voy a probar con un ejemplo.
No voy a hacer uno de estos casos que nos están pidiendo, voy a hacer un ejemplo más simple.
Supongamos que tenemos "x" al cuadrado
y eso elevado al cubo.
Bueno, ¿qué significa esto?
"x" cuadrada elevado al cubo,
esto significa que estamos multiplicando "x" cuadrada, por "x" cuadrada, por "x" cuadrada,
estamos multiplicando "x" cuadrada por sí misma
3 veces, eso es lo que significa.
"x" cuadrada, por "x" cuadrada, por "x" cuadrada...
Y esto, ¿a qué es igual?
Bueno podemos verlo de 2 maneras,
primero recordando la regla del producto de exponentes.
Esto de aquí es "x" al cuadrado 3 veces, es decir,
"x" elevado a la 2 más 2, más 2,
y esto de aquí es equivalente a "x" a la 3 por 2,
lo cual es igual a "x" a la sexta.
De otra manera tú podrías decir ¡Oye Sal!
yo no entiendo esta regla de producto, bueno entonces,
fíjate que aquí tenemos que "x" cuadrada
es equivalente a "x", por "x",
por otra vez "x" cuadrada, "x" por "x"
y estoy poniendo entre paréntesis las "x" cuadrada,
así es que aquí es por "x" por "x".
¿Y qué tenemos aquí?
"x" por "x" 6 veces,
"x", por "x",  por "x", por "x", por "x", por "x".
Aquí lo que tenemos es "x" a la sexta potencia,
es por eso que podemos sumar
los exponentes de esta manera.
Apliquemos entonces la regla de potencias para esta expresión, para empezar tenemos "x" al cubo
elevado a la cuarta potencia,
esto es entonces "x" a la 3 por 4
"x" a la potencia 12
y eso está multiplicado por
"x" al cuadrado elevado a la quinta potencia
y esto es simplemente "x" a la 2 por 5,
"x" a la décima potencia.
Y ahora tenemos la misma base,
estamos haciendo el producto,
podemos simplemente sumar los exponentes,
así es que esto de aquí es igual a
"x" elevado a la potencia 12 más 10
ó "x" elevado a la potencia 22.
Y ya hemos terminado.